[Music]
Jordan it is wonderful to be here with
you today so great to be here with you
so exciting so let's start you made
history as the youngest black playwright
in Broadway history which is incredible
how did that make you feel insane you
know insane like it's something you
don't even really think about you know
cuz you're too busy just doing the work
but to think about the fact that you
know the person before for me was
Lorraine henbury wrote a raising in the
sun in 1958 you know so to think that
I'm like following in that in that
Footsteps in that lineage just excites
me and also you know to me is the
beginning of the future the beginning of
a new kind of Storytelling and a new
kind of theater A New Kind of Broadway
you
know I want to hear about your
background how did you get into Theater
Broadway and entertainment all sudden
when I was really young like about 6
years old I would always put on these
plays in my living room room and I would
cut up my mom's weave and my dad's work
uniform and make
costumes I really just like love telling
stories and love becoming other
characters and so that started with like
me doing plays in the living room to
going to the backyard to Growing from
the backyard to doing them in the church
and so that just grew and then when I
moved to New York I would like hand out
flyers in Time Square and like on the
subway trying to like pass out and let
people know that my shows were happening
and that just grew and grew and then I
did ain't no mo at the public theater
and and then it went from the public
theater to
Broadway how did you convince producers
to to take a chance on you and take a
chance on ain't noo and get it to
Broadway yeah you know what's crazy is I
really had to do a lot of the work
myself first really yeah because it was
one of those pieces where it just wasn't
like anything else you know when people
want you to compare something to
something it's like I don't really know
what it's comparative to but really I
had to believe in myself and believe in
my work before I I trusted other people
to believe in it for me right and I
think that started with putting on
readings like with the community like
finding different different
organizations that would let me just set
up music stands and call friends and
read a play right and I think once I
started doing that that's when Jack
Phils Moore from the public theater
ended up seeing a reading of it that was
done in New York Theater Workshop with
TV Walker web and it just kind of grew
from
there and how were you able to like
break into to the Hollywood scene
convinced bet to take a chance on you
what was that process like for you oh
that was a journey so so the Miss Pat
show I was 23 when I wrode it and I
actually wrode it in my apartment I
y'all I used to live in this in this
horrible New York apartment I didn't
have a closet I slept on a futon I
always said I had five roommates and two
rats cuz it was just a mess I wrote that
pilot Lee Daniels brought brought me to
Fox and Miss Pat brought me to Fox and
they were like absolutely not we're not
giving a kid in College a television
show I don't care how good his plays are
they're like we we're not we're not
doing that right so Lee's like you know
well we we're going to keep trying and
Miss Pat calls me and she said I want
you to do something for me I want you to
write the first episode and I was like
what she was like write the first
episode and take your name off of it I
was like what do you mean take my name
off of it so I took my name off of it I
wrote the episode trusting and she sent
it in to Fox her and Lee Daniels and fox
said who wrote this
and they said it was the kids you didn't
want to
hire what a good strategy yeah and
that's how I ended up like being able to
T have my own show yeah that's really
cool and finally Jordan I'm sure you've
got a lot of rejection in your career
being in theater being in Hollywood tell
me about that experience for you and any
advice you have for others who may be
pitching or going through similar
rejections in their field yeah don't let
nobody talk you out of what you know to
be true right because
if they can't give you the space you can
find the space if you got to do it in
the living room if you got to do it in
the backyard if you got to do it at the
Rex in or do it there's always some form
of you're not good enough there's always
some form of we don't get it we don't
understand it that's too much that's too
you know what I'm grateful for is
because I've received so many NOS at
some point Spirit just knock something
into my head it's like do you know who
you are do you know what you've done
when people told you you couldn't do it
when people said it was impossible and I
think that that's what's really you know
pushed me forward is to never ever ever
take no for an answer when there's a yes
in the bottom of your
[Music]
gut